are you ready for some high-flying
web-slinging action well you'll get it
sooner than you think
I'm Tony and this gamespot News Update
is sure to get your spidey senses
tingling Marvel's Ryan Penn agos
appeared on a live stream and let's slip
that insomniacs ps4 exclusive spider-man
game is coming this year the moment was
captured by reddit user gaming since 95
where Pinocchio's also mentioned the
upcoming Marvel vs. Capcom infinite
although that game is not a ps4
exclusive we haven't heard much about
spider-man since its e3 2016 reveal but
a statement from a marvel exact seems
pretty reliable be sure to subscribe to
be the first to know when a more
specific release date is announced
insomniac spider-man isn't the only
major Marvel game on the horizon either
earlier this year Marvel announced the
Avengers project a multi game
partnership with Square Enix although
any details on that are pretty scarce
but for more comic-book action right now
why not visit our GameSpot Universe
channel
[Music]